if you're listening to this and you know
you don't identify as somebody who's
an addict in the traditional sense I
would encourage all of you to think more
objectively and and really do you know
do an analysis A forensic analysis on on
how you live your life every single day
and I I don't think there's anybody out
there who who won't be able to you know
see and identify some Behavior pattern
whether it's a tendency to get into a
certain kind of relationship or a
certain kind of social Dynamic that you
perpetuate despite negative outcomes
there is always something that can be
pinpointed that needs a little redress
and I think you know there is a path
forward that can allow you to ultimately
transcend it